the beard is gone the hair is gone they
called the other Tuesday is right here
what not
so maybe you heard this story in the
news recently the UN Population Fund
says the world is about to add its 7
billion 'the person the UN says the
world's population will reach a
milestone this Monday 7 billion people
world's population will hit seven
billion seven billion seven billion come
Halloween there will be so many of us on
earth that it's actually kind of scary
it appears that the good old human race
is now seven billion strong that's 9
zeros 133 times around the world counted
in step 200 years to count allowed
starting from 1 2 3 4 I did it so most
of what I write is science fiction and
the reason I love sci-fi is because I
believe that talking about our future is
the best way to day to talk about our
present whereas in the past the best way
to talk about our presents talk about
our past put it this way the rate of
technological evolution being so fast
our actions today directly implicate the
situation tomorrow the present is so
close to our future that it's like the
shingles on the roof of the half years
days moments almost overlapping science
fiction can explore this intimate
relationship anywhere from the gutter to
the very top all the time warning that
if the structure isn't sound the roof
will collapse when I tell people I write
sci-fi I get the same question again and
again what happens when there are too
many people what happens when the world
becomes overpopulated well it's a good
question and one I try to address in my
first long fiction a novella called big
city I put the link to that whole book
online for your pleasure you can find it
in the doobly-doo but let's return to
the idea of population growth if you
want to know anything about this subject
you have to start with Thomas Malthus
and his book an essay on the principle
of population was malthus's idea that
humans are the only animal on earth that
increases its population beyond its
available resources basically we grow
faster than we create food it leaves us
with a whole hell of a lot of people who
are under fed and malnourished to
Malthus humanity grows exponentially
nothing not even the plague or two world
wars can put so much as a blip in that
graph in the year 1800 we were 1 billion
strong 200 years later and we're 7
obviously we can't keep growing forever
so eventually we're gonna hit an
asymptote and level out what scientists
have a very hard time agreeing on what
that number will be guesses range from
10 billion to 20 bill here's what we do
during the
agricultural and industrial revolutions
the life expectancy of children
increased dramatic between 1730 and 1810
'the percentage of children who died
before the age of five decreased from
seventy four point five to thirty one
point eight advances in medicine like
compulsory vaccination have increased
the life expectancy from 38 in 1850 to
78 in 2011 a rural population growth
rate hit its peak during the 1960's baby
boom at just over 2% ridiculously high
some people started to freak out like
Paul Elroy to predicted in his 1968 book
the Population Bomb that we were headed
for severe famines worldwide
fortunately Ehrlich was wrong innovation
stepped in and saved the day and in this
case innovations name was Norman burlap
more than half the farmers of the world
live in a subsistence agriculture
outside of the economies of their own
country they have had very little or no
money with which to make purchases of
the many items that you need for a
decent life Borlaug is the father of the
Green Revolution initiatives to develop
higher yield crops using synthetic
fertilizers and hybridize see the Nobel
Committee estimated that in 1970 by the
time he received the prize he had saved
a billion lives don't you just feel like
in his acceptance speech he said
there can be no permanent progress in
the battle against hunger until the
agencies that fight for increased food
production and those that fight for
population control unite in a common
efforts true that the growth rate has
been falling ever since the baby boom
and chances are it won't reach that
right ever again but consider this
diagram while birth rates in the
developed world decrease and level out
around 1.7 children per woman in
sub-saharan Africa the rate remains at
five or more or take a look at the
distribution of ages in the developed
and undeveloped world look at how many
children there are in the latter
sub-saharan Africa is also where we see
the most poverty and malnourished
clearly there is a connection between
fertility rate and quality of live it
tells us that a large part of the
problem concerning population growth can
be addressed by the empowerment of women
that's joel coen a mathematical
biologists and author of educating all
children a global agenda saying that not
only is nutrition a vital part of
balancing population growth and hunger
but also the use of contraception and
most importantly education you can find
the link to his Amazon page in the
doobly-doo I want to make one final
point on population growth and I'll have
Malthus help me out again I believe that
it is the intention of the Creator that
earth should be replenished but
certainly with a healthy virtuous and
happy population not an unhealthy
vicious and miserable one and in
endeavouring to obey the command to
increase and multiply we people at only
with beings of this latter description
and suffer accordingly we have no right
to impeach the justice of the command
but only our rational mode of executed
the justice of the commit here he's
talking about God's just desire for us
to multiply and grow of course that's
Phooey there is no god but there's no
question that as a species unlike every
other species on earth we have the
innate desire to procreate
part of it is evolutionary but the
question must be is all of it evolution
do you want to have kids because you
want to ensure the future survival of
the human race or do you want them for
other reasons social reasons because
it's strange not to or personal reasons
because you crave a specific kind of
love because you want to be needed even
secret reasons secret to yourself
because you know that you will die and
there's no escaping it in one way to
ease the pain of that is to know that
someone will remember you and tell about
you in it in that you achieve a kind of
immortality humanity can outgrow its
evolutionary instructions by the time
you die how many times do you think
you'll have had sex to procreate and how
many times just for pleasure advances in
medicine will allow us to live longer
just as we jumped from 38 to 78 in 150
years advances in technology will not
only allow our world to be energy
independent but our cell imagine getting
all the sustenance you need from the Sun
imagine living to the age of 200 when
you'll really be able to count to 7
Villa maybe it seems out dirty but
evolution like population is exponential
and when we can live as long as we want
what will happen to our desire to
procreate to have chilled there is no
easy way to answer this question but I
do my best to try in a second long
fiction a novel called all languages the
road
coming soon